let's do a few more examples from the
orders of magnitude exercise earth is
approximately 1 times 10 to the seventh
meters in diameter which of the
following could be Earth's diameter so
this is just an approximation it's an
estimate and they're saying which of
these if I wanted to estimate it would
be close sort would be 1 times 10 to the
seventh and the key here does realize
that 1 times 10 to the seventh one times
10 to the seventh is the same thing as
one followed by seven zeroes one two
three four five six seven we put some
commas here so we make it a little bit
more readable or another way of talking
about it is it is 1 times 10 to the
seventh is the same thing as 10 million
so which of these if we were to really
roughly estimate we would go to 10
million well this right over here is one
point two seven one million or 1 million
270 1543 if I were to really roughly
estimated I might go to 1 million but
I'm not going to go to 10 million so I'd
rule that out this is 12 million seven
hundred fifteen thousand four hundred
thirty if I were to roughly estimate
this well yeah I would go to ten million
ten million is if I were to just if I
wanted to really just look one digit to
represent it if I would write this in
scientific notation this right over here
this right over here is one point two
seven one five four three times ten to
the seventh let me write that down
twelve million seven hundred and fifteen
thousand four hundred and thirty if I
were to write this in scientific
notation is one point two seven one five
four three times ten to the seventh and
when you write it this way say hey well
if I was really estimate this and get
pretty rough with it and I just rounded
this down I would make this one times
ten to the seventh so this really does
look like our best choice now let me
just verify well this right over here if
I were to round it I go to a hundred
million or one times 10 to the eighth
that's way too big and this if I were to
run it out go to a billion or one times
ten to the ninth so that's also too big
so once again this feels like the best
answer now let's try a couple more so
here we're asked how many times larger
is seven times 10 to the fifth then one
times 10 to the fourth well we could
just divide to think about that
seven times 10 to the fifth divided by 1
times 10 to the 4th well this is the
same thing as 7 over 1 times 10 to the
5th over 10 to the 4th which is just
going to be equal to well 7 divided by 1
is 7 and 10 to the 5th that's that's 10
being or multiplying 5 tens and then
this is and then you're dividing by 4 10
so you're going to have one 10 left over
or if you remember your exponent
properties this would be the same thing
as 10 to the 5 minus 4 power or 10 to
the first power so this right over here
all of this business all of this
business is going to simplify to 10 to
the 1st or like next write it this way
this would be the same thing as 10 to
the 5 minus 4 which is equal to 10 to
the 1 which is just equal to 10 so this
is 7 times 10 which is equal to 70 so 7
times 10 to the 5th is 70 times 70 times
larger than 1 times 10 to the 4th let's
do one more so here they're asking us 3
times 10 to the 9th is 30 thousand times
larger than what number so once again we
can divide so we have 3 times 10 to the
9th 3 times 10 to the 9th is 30 thousand
times larger than what number so let's
just divide by 30,000 and see what we
get and here we've written something in
kind of a exponential notation or which
is a scientific notation actually and
here we just wrote the number out so one
way we could do it is we could either
write this number out and then divide or
we could write this in scientific
notation so let's do it either way so if
we were to write if we would expand the
top number out if we would expand this
out we could write that as 3 followed by
9 zeros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 we put some
commas here to make it readable and then
we're dividing that by 3 followed by 4
zeros 1 2 3 4 and then we could cancel
out the zeros we could say okay let's
divide the top and the bottom by 10
let's divide it by another 10
by another 10 by another 10 and then
let's see we've done all the dividing by
10 and now let's divide the top and the
bottom by 3 so this would become a 1
this would become a 1 so on the bottom
we're just left with the 1 and we'd have
1 followed by 1 2 3 4 5 0 so this would
be 1 followed by one two three four five
zeros or 100,000 now let's write it both
both of these in scientific notation so
3 times 10 to the ninth I'm just going
to rewrite that as 3 times 10 to the
ninth and we're dividing that by 30,000
which is the exact same thing as 3 times
10 to though we have 1 2 3 4 zeros here
1 3 times 10 to the 4th or I guess I
really should say we have 4 places after
the 3 so 1 2 3 4 so 10 3 times 10 to the
4th and so we could divide the 3 by the
3 and then that will simplify so 3
divided by 3 is just 1 and then 10 to
the 9th divided by 10 to the 4th well
that's going to be 10 to the 9 minus 4
10 to the 5th this is going to be 1
times 10 to the 5th which once again is
1 followed by 5 zeros or the exact same
thing as 100,000 so it's 30,000 times
larger than 100,000